ok gotta slow down I have six all right
names oh who is a fan of the NIMS out
Indian defense because that's exactly
what we have right here d4c for e6 move
both nights out pin I'm going to go
immediately for it I want to be assured
of this structure otherwise there might
be a quick bishop out night out type of
thing since I don't have a dark squared
Bishop my pawns want to be on dark
squares to coordinate well with my
remaining bishop now what I might look
into e4 ok after three is preventing
that and still allowing for a g4 move
something I was voicing in previous
streams did I play ed bogo before and
this was like I had black and we were
entering the same setup I wonder about
that let's go at c5 and then knight c6 I
don't know if I want to Castle kingside
so quickly ok my night can't play to c6
and clearly here is probably best so
let's go here right now right here right
now and I might be wanting to take steps
towards the kingside that f8 g6
so we're gonna see about that definitely
gonna see some now now what's the scoop
all right I don't know if I want to
allow that Bishop to play to g5 actually
I'm quite all right with that Bishop
lying there because that's going to help
me eventually gained a clamp on that F
foursquare I think if Bishop there I was
going to play h6 and then maybe g5 and
then night to g6 okay well what do you
do because I'm still a bit concerned
about this night maneuver no I'm not
going to make that pond no just dad if
the bishop plays here I can throw a
question to it I have a night h4
available could definitely be pressure
on this pond soon maybe night here and
then trying to get to f4 for some reason
it just seems very very familiar like
here and then get it to f4 i'm going to
try that focusing on the f4 square now
if it is prevented I think coming
immediately back with my night is best I
do accomplish some things very small but
whoa ok so this King is saying you know
what I'm ready to take a hike I don't
want to deal with whatever's gonna come
on over here he's going to try and get
over here you seeing this is a home so
what do you do what is it that you do
here I think um let's get some trades
and I'm going with this night because if
there is a capture on this square I
could be taking with this pawn and then
make use of e5 with this night and there
I guess there is
kind of a general rule I would follow if
you're interfering instances if you're
in positions in a chess game where both
of your nights can be making use of a
particular square I think the ones that
are nearest to the edge of the board are
the ones you should maybe be as a
general rule maybe go with the ones that
are closest to the edge of the board
have them make use of it because he was
a bit more displaced than this night so
we're just having some exchanges here
let's let's go with this and now I think
I just want to castle and then look for
f5 I want to open the position up which
might seem a bit odd because my opponent
has the bishop pair but they have the
bishop pair and the less safe King
that's another way to kind of view
things and before I castle i think i
could just run with this move right now
because here's one thing i want to be
assured that this break comes in if i
were to castle and g4 is played I get
the F foursquare for my night but I
don't get this break-in and this is I
think the more purposeful of the 2 i'd
much rather get app on break in and have
a file open up than to be able to make
use of an f4 square you follow that
those are the two that i was just
weighing do I care about having they
have four square for my night or do I
care more about an open f file it's the
open f file I want my Brooks to play and
I want to go after this king my queen
could come out in this direction maybe
it's not looking too exciting over here
this is covered this is covered so this
is the a5 square definitely have that in
mind Castle open it up pawn takes is the
threat this Bishop is unprotected and in
the line of fire right now okay this is
the this is the domino effect going on
now
pieces start to fall one pond falls and
then that's that's all that's pretty
much it isn't it very very difficult to
defend now pawn takes rook takes bishop
there's Queen checks maybe I think I'm
castling King side would have been okay
for white instead of the decision to run
in this direction trying to have this be
safe but i think i'm a netting material
now after this capture Bishop takes I
play Queen f6 the bishops hit twice and
I think the King needs to come over
something to defend okay have this
instead well you know I think okay wait
just do this or here just this right
away let them fancy just exchange now I
did consider this move first maybe it
was a little bit better just give up on
back and then play here and if h5 then I
could at least come to a nice square
with my night right here okay actually I
could do this first though if King takes
I throw in a check and then I could make
use of this square if pawn takes Knight
I come all the way back to recapture
okay let's throw in the check I really
don't want to play here keep it in the
center give back some material keep that
King Center this pond is hit less than
45 and okay
another pond Forks right around every
corner here here Bishop back there's
pond push I could get that rook I really
want to go after it oh I should just
take in the bishop take that bishop and
then play here that was stupid rook
takes bishop was better see that see
that slip I was already talking about
this square in this square I should have
should have made this one should have
made that one work it's gonna get rid of
that keep it really simple the Queen out
push these ponds can't be defended okay
just Queen trade watch out for me here
watch out for those sneaky mates get the
Queen's off push away get a queen with
check there's no need to recapture that
right away all right yeah resignation
good game let's flip this board let's go
back here and see how either one of us
could have made different decisions here
so I think this is I think that this is
fine this structure that what has and
now I mean right here I don't think that
there's a too much you need to worry
about um maybe g3 somehow you get g3 in
or maybe just castle I think castle
would be okay and then if castle and I
throw a night on f4 maybe you could then
just do g3 I really i don't think i
would be wanting to take this Bishop
because he's a he's a bad bishop
maybe I'd be taking the night I think
going with just castle and g3 to watch
over the f4 square just being a bit more
patient and not feeling the need to just
run for the hills in this direction and
keep in mind going in this in this way
over here to the queenside it's not yet
you cannot safely say that this is going
to be a nice home it could open up I
could be doing be five or something or
queen coming out here so I think just
castle and if a night here I could you
could play g3 it's true that I can be
making use of age three but after King
g2 I am in a spot where I have minor
pieces having to babysit minor pieces
and that's not too comfortable for me so
that's that's my main suggestion just
going with the kingside castle and then
should a night end up on f4 consider
then the g3 move or if my queen starts
to get active maybe could kick her
around Bishop f2 maybe queen to see one
guarding these a g5 h1 squares I don't
think I could get my queen out here to
cause too much trouble but anyhow that's
what I'm thinking here King side castle